méxico sumó otro triste hito en la
pandemia cuatro días después de superar
el millón de casos el país rompió la
barrera de las 100 mil muertes tras
reportar 576 en las últimas 24 horas es
el cuarto país en sumar esa cantidad de
fallecimientos después de eeuu brasil e
india- una cifra preocupante e
impactante incluso para los altos cargos
de salud esta es una cantidad desde
luego
inusual no tenía ningún antecedente
previo la sociedad mexicana de una
enfermedad infecciosa aguda que pudiera
causar una propagación tan rápida y
afectar la vida de tantas personas
aunque las autoridades señalan que los
decesos presentan una tendencia a la
baja los casos están repuntando en
algunas partes del país como el estado
de chihuahua en la frontera norte que
regresó al nivel máximo de alerta
la situación también empeoró en ciudad
de méxico que permanece en el segundo
nivel de alerta el gobierno local ha
dispuesto carpas móviles para realizar
pruebas entre los ciudadanos los
profesionales de la salud piden no bajar
la guardia es muy importante que esto lo
tomen en serio no es un juego uno de
este lado se esfuerza por brindarles la
protección las medidas de información y
las tomas de muestra pero si uno como
persona no hace caso no acata las
instrucciones de nada sirve y al
contrario los contagios van a la alta
los especialistas advierten que existe
una división entre los mexicanos entre
aquellos que descuidan las medidas de
protección y los que entran rápidamente
en pánico también señalan que la
cercanía de las fiestas ha incentivado a
los ciudadanos a salir a hacer compras
aumentando la cantidad de personas en
las calles y el riesgo de contagio